the thing that's not moving is this red  spot down in the far southeast corner of  your screen that is northbound i-11 or  the 95-515  coming out of henderson you might want  to change your plans now the rest of the  freeway system has the usual slowdowns  no crashes but let's take you down here  because this is a pretty big deal it  appears to be construction related lane  restrictions if you have the chance  maybe you're stuck in the backups at  before horizon but i would take horizon  east over to boulder highway then you  can get back on at lake mead because  between here and there you got upwards  of a 10 to 15 minute delay here's our  live picture northbound on the i-11  looks like they may be taking the cones  down here but in the meantime it is a  huge slowdown and the folks trying to  get on from horizon drive that is a  pretty big deal as well